hello Conan O'Brien here for the past
two weeks we've been featuring prominent
black voices on our program and I would
like to continue that tonight earlier
today I had a fantastic conversation
with Senator Cory Booker I do not want
to waste any time so let's get right to
that interview my guest tonight was the
mayor of Newark New Jersey from 2006 to
2013 he's also the first
african-american senator from New Jersey
and was a candidate for the Democratic
nomination in the 2020 presidential
election I am very honored to welcome
senator Corrie Booker senator how are
you I'm well Conan thank you for having
me on again I want you to know I put on
a nice shirt for you this is my [ __ ]
talking to a senator shirt god we could
have done an agreement beforehand a
mutual disarmament and I know I shirt on
and and relax when I when I wear a tie I
look like a kid these days that found
his dad's tie so I'm trying to show you
respect but not overdo it you know maybe
one day you'll show me the ultimate
respect and for an interview in the
future you will you will be bald because
that would that would be the greatest
act of respect and deference it's a good
look for you it would not be a good look
for me
all right you could pull it off thank
you for doing this I know you must be
slammed and really busy but it's a
thrill to talk to you because there's so
much everybody is trying to process and
and and understand at the moment one of
the things I wanted to start with is
that we both you and I lived through the
riots following the the release of the
video of Rodney King's beating and and
and the riots that followed the beam the
police officers being let go and I was
here in Los Angeles at the time you
lived through those riots I know as well
and am I correct these what's happened
since the death of George Floyd feels
very different
does it feel different to you well in
some ways I know that that moment very
well it was probably one of the most
explosive personal moments in my life
where I often channeled energy and anger
and every way I could to try to advance
issues I was a college student but I
lost control that night I wrote a column
for Stanford's newspaper about why have
I lost control with an title of it and
it was just this this explosion of a
lifetime worth of experiences where
you're followed and surveilled and
stopped and had guns drawn on you and
here I was at a point where I was a
president in my class a football player
Stanford on my way to Oxford to study
and I just felt like I'm still at this
point where black men in America is
putting their lives at risk every time
they have an interaction and here when I
saw clearly on a videotape 50-plus blows
to this man that everybody a good
conscious can just say that was wrong
that you had that verdict and here I was
again 30 years later I remember that
night I remember marching in the streets
in Northern California and any and and
this feeling came up in me again after a
Matar brie jogging in his community
Brianna Taylor sleeping in her home a
guy bird-watching was threatened with
something that black men know could
result in beating being beaten being
arrested being grown in jails and then
you see this torture of a human being
until they died and mmin a time where
you're brokenhearted not just a fear of
black I just a big believer if America
hasn't broken your heart you don't love
her enough when this kind of stuff goes
on and has now that's been about 30
years ago so I am I hopeful you know I
think you you have to be a prisoner of
hope because America in it of itself is
a testimony to people under the most
wretched conditions hoping for better
and so yeah it's amazing for me to see
50 space plus a dozen countries people
protesting small towns with in big
cities diversity of age of race and then
to be in a position like a senator where
I could write a
that could not I'm telling you right now
could not have been written a month ago
and get the majority of the Democrats in
the House and the Senate to sign on
quickly couldn't have been done if it
wasn't for the protest so yeah I'm
really hopeful because there's one thing
I know and I know you love history
if there's one truism that's true about
America its advancement from the
suffrage movement to workers rights to
civil rights to LGBTQ rights is a change
doesn't come from Washington it comes to
Washington all of those great
advancements were preceded by Americans
getting up off of the couch and getting
involved in protest in pushing and
demanding that their government leap
forward and this has got to be one of
those moments I I often when people
asked me about history or the country I
always say the same thing America is a
work in progress it's always been a work
in progress and there's a lot to do and
then unfortunately it almost feels that
we we've experienced way too many of
these moments where we realize how much
we have to do how much work we have to
do well I think it's a disconnection
where we have a poverty of empathy for
each other and you know King in his
letter from Birmingham jail I posted
them on my Instagram account this one
section where he says what worries me
more than the Ku Klux Klan and the white
Citizens Council is actually white
moderates he was saying call this out
this idea that people who don't feel
moved enough to get involved in the in
changing the injustice is that they
would themselves admit and and so we're
this moment I think where it is a test
to will we address that poverty of
empathy and I see signs that we are
because these problems cannot be solved
with the same levels of empathy and love
with which that allowed them to fester
for so long we need to raise the level
of love and love is not an emic word
it's not saccharine it love is actually
sacrifice and service for those who are
suffering and and/or struggling and so
this to me is really one of those
moments where we are at a crossroads in
American history and and my hope is that
this becomes one of those big moments
where we all look back and when
were asked by our children or
grandchildren what did you do when
America was at a crossroads did you sit
at home and hope and wish and and cheer
on the sidelines or did you get on the
streets or get engage in a way to made
it happen and and that's my prayer
because my grandmother black woman I
would ask her those questions where were
you when this happened I still remember
World War two she wasn't storming
beaches in Normandy but she bragged to
me that she had Victory Gardens and she
bought war bonds and she was a part of
the effort that's when we're at our best
we were all invested and that's still
the test that's going on right now as
will we all be invested I know I've been
trying to talk to people about their
personal stories I know that you had the
experience of your parents talking to
you when you were 12 or 13 years old
about being careful when you went out in
the world because the color of your skin
puts you in peril yeah I think that's
the thing I've you know I hate he's his
word I feel a lot of shame about because
my parents did the right thing for a
young boy that by the time he was 12 or
13 was over six feet tall and that they
knew that this world would potentially
see me as a threat and and I had
conversations early on especially around
the time I got a driver's license were
my parents you know not just told me to
be careful but you know made me of
sufficiently afraid to protect my life
and I guess when I say shame I'm not a
shameful about my parents who are
generation were they their circles had
stories about vicious interactions with
with police or authorities but I think
the shame that I'm talking to is that
I've had 30 years of adulthood now and
and and now I have to tell my nephews
and my mentees I have to give them the
same lesson that we shouldn't have to
give in America to to kids and so it
hurts a lot that this tradition this
awful wretched tradition continues in
this country and it needs to end
I was speaking to a friend of mine at
comedian Ron Funches on last night's
show his son's autistic and he said for
years he's worried that his son would
act out in public and because of the
color of his skin his life would be at
risk if the police had to intervene and
but it's not any rational theater we kid
people are shot holding a cell phone
people are shot reaching for a pen and
then and then those officers who use it
that awful unleash that awful violence
you can say that they were afraid so I
this has been a week where I talked to a
lot of my african-american friends who
are parents and it every conversation it
just hurts at a level that it's just
difficult and you feel weary and you
feel exhausted and sick and tired and
and but at the same time you know you
you have to engage in an impossible
alchemy that that better generations in
us have engaged in that somehow you can
transform that hurt and that pain and
even trauma for many into change into an
expansion of the consciousness of others
into love and and and so many
communities in America I have had to
enforce to bring forth that that that
rare magic where you have to turn hate
and and and and complicity into unto
action to save your own lives and to
save the soul of your country the yeah I
want to specifically talk about the
police because this is a conversation in
the last two weeks that's that's
morphing and changing all the time and
and and it feels now we're in a moment
of talking about how specifically can we
do something to make sure that these
deadly conflicts with the police are
don't exist which might be applying this
guy dream but are certainly much less
frequent and you have a bill that you've
that you've put forth the the justice
in policing act of 2020 what are the
specific things in that bill that you
think could make a difference so I want
to confess to you it may be the broadest
police accountability bill ever in the
history of our country but it's very
narrow it's so it's it's stopping stuff
that's just common sense you shouldn't
joke holds racial religious profiling
no-knock warrants a whole bunch of these
practices in some cities are banned that
should not should be the law of the land
for America number two it just says hey
if you really violate the law if you do
engage in criminal behavior you should
be held accountable for that behavior
and so it creates a better platform for
criminal prosecution on the federal
level a standard that's that's
achievable for people who do seriously
wrong and if you violate someone's civil
rights you that you are you no longer
have something called qualified immunity
and then the last thing which is just so
obvious to me as well is that you know
sunshine is the ultimate disinfectant if
every department has to report up their
uses of force their police misconduct it
creates the ability for an average
citizen all the way to a person a Senate
to be able to hold a department
accountable and stop some things are
bizarre in this country where someone in
one city can create or do awful
accidents of police misconduct quit that
department moved to another city and get
hired without that new department even
knowing about their record so this is a
broad strong bill but I'm gonna tell you
when I say it's narrowly tailored it
does not ultimately solve the larger
problems of our society what I mean by
that is King said I can't legislate you
two to love me but I can stop you from
lynching me so this is a bill that
starts to stop what we saw with Eric
garner and Brianna Taylor I can go
through that but what is the larger call
of activists this is the beauty and a
lot of things that I'm hearing right now
is again back to that issue is what is
the quality of our mercy what is the
level of our love in America because
everybody could talk to people on both
sides of the aisle I've talked to law
enforcement officers Mike my first
meeting with the FBI when I was mayor of
my city when we were going through gang
intelligence and I asked this guy just
to see what response would be
we solved this problem and the head of
the FBI says to me we don't solve this
problem because the law enforcement
officials in our country are dealing
with symptoms they're dealing with our
lack of love and mercy towards each
other 20 percent of our incarceration
czar for drug people with drug
addictions and suffering with drug abuse
problems and we don't give them help we
give them prison in jails put them back
on the streets they get re-arrested
multiple times costing us hundreds of
thousands of dollars before they might
find their way into treatment people
with mental illness we criminalize them
for our health care issue and don't get
them the treatment we throw them in our
prisons and jails low-income people we
have criminalized poverty in this
country any American who knows when you
have to make this terrible decision do I
pay for a traffic violation which now is
resulted in a warrant for my arrest or
do i or do I pay my rent or put food on
the table for my kids
we have been defunding public education
we have been defunding the kind of
things I can show you the data that
social scientists can show you prove
that would lower crime and our need for
police in the first place so my bill
that I wrote with Kamala Harris
and the head of the Congressional Black
Caucus and Natalie an incredible
coalition to just hold police
accountable is important but what we
should be striving for don't we have a
greater moral imagination in our country
that we can that we've created a police
state we are four to five percent of the
globe's population but one out of every
four incarcerated people on the planet
Earth is in the land of the free one out
of every three incarcerated women on the
planet Earth is in the land of the free
and it's such a racially biased system
that we are now at a point in America
where there are more african-americans
under criminal supervision prison jail
probation parole than all the slaves in
1850 what is the quality of our mercy
what is the level of our love that's
what the artists of activism on the
streets are beginning to call for can't
we be a society that stops problems
before they happen and then we throw it
all onto our police and our prisons
never really truly affirming human
dignity and and and actualize a human
potential it forced me I had a
conversation of the day with W kamau
Bell
who
made a point that has resonated with me
ever since that's what I go to sleep
thinking about and what I wake up
thinking about which is this is about
all of us doing our work meaning rather
than yes there need to be institutional
changes in some of the ways that we
enforce the law there needs to be
accountability these are things that are
clearly true there but it is it is false
to say this is all up to other people
meaning for me to sit back and say
someone fixed the police and then I'm
here I'm just gonna watch the news and
see if that happens everybody has to be
accountable everybody has to practice
empathy everyday and sensitivity that
it's a it's a practice the way you know
goes a practice or or you know any other
exercise is a practice or religion is a
practice it's something that you have to
engage in all the time yeah Coenen I'm
here in part because of a white guy who
was doing nothing on a couch in New
Jersey for years before it's born 65 is
watching a movie back when we had three
channels most of America's watching
judgment at Nuremburg the movie is cut
in two because of something going on on
a bridge called the Edmund Pettus Bridge
he watches John Lewis mothers being beat
viciously it's we know it is Bloody
Sunday and a white guy on the suburbs on
a couch stands up he's so moved he
doesn't allow his inability to do
everything to undermine his
determination to do something and he
decides to go to Alabama than last he
can't afford a plane ticket he just
started a business but he says you know
what one hour a week I'm gonna do
something and he calls he finds these
activists that are helping to break
housing segregation because black
families are being turned away from the
suburbs of New Jersey and he goes to
four years later he's got a sting
operation set up he's representing a
family they were turned away from a
house a white couple posing as them gets
the gets to buy the house they put a bid
on on the day of the closing lawyer
black man attacked by the real estate
agent with dogs punched in the face long
behold they eventually move into this
incredible nurturing home and a great
community's great public schools that
was my family that guy represented my
family because in the
moment he stood up and said I'm just
gonna give an hour a week if he didn't
do that I might not be sitting here
having this conversation and to say any
of us are powerless is to surrender our
power to say any of us are not
responsible is to be complicit in the
very injustice which we criticize and so
the question is is what what are you
gonna do at all of us we have to read
more texts from people and good faith in
good will saying I don't know what to do
what can I do and my response has not
been to tell me what to do
my response is to never let go of that
question every day wrestle with that
question let it want you let it push you
to always say I'm doing something
something in the cause of my country
because we all every one of us drink
deeply from wells of freedom and liberty
and privilege that we didn't dig we are
here because of people that were willing
to die we are all are at no matter who
we are we this what we're living as our
ancestors wildest dreams but you cheapen
it and degrade it if you don't continue
with that commitment so that our
great-grandchildren will one day be
living in an America beyond our dreams
that really does and as a nation that's
in search of herself it really does make
real on the promise that we're we have
liberty and justice for all you've
spoken a lot and about empathy and it's
impossible for me not to mention we've
actually had almost two weeks of shows I
believe now we're we've not once
mentioned the Pres the United States
because I I haven't wanted him to be a
part of the conversation I have wanted
the conversation to go deeper than that
but I'll bring him up now because we
have a leader of the country who I think
everyone would agree has a chronic
inability to demonstrate empathy and I I
feel that that has been a situation like
what happened after the killing of
George Floyd is as crazy as it sounds
it's an opportunity for change it's an
opportunity for the president to bring
us all together and to say beautiful
things that might actually bring about
lasting change
I feel that that has been squandered in
but by our president yes why I love you
for not centering him in your
conversations because it's not it's not
about him this election is coming up is
not a referendum on one guy in one
office it's really referendum on who we
are and who we're gonna be to each other
and we've got to raise the frequency in
our nation in terms of the love and
empathy but you mention him so let me
just say this I just fundamentally
believe and I've watched leaders on both
sides of the aisle demonstrate this you
can't lead the people if you don't love
the people and and he just does not love
all America you don't have to agree with
all Americans but he is his willingness
to so cavalierly deny so many Americans
human dignity for him to trample upon
the the the the very humanity of other
Americans to cheapen this nation by
working so hard to divide us and to make
us hate each other all of those things
mean he is illegitimate in the kind of
moral leadership that we need he may
have the trappings of power he may have
the title of the office but the the
title doesn't make the man the man has
to make the title and he has been a
failure a failure in a moral law office
that Republicans from Lincoln to
Democrats like Obama who have led with
love for their country with malice
towards none with charity towards all
he's had so much malice toward so many
and so little charity towards others so
I want this to be a moral moment in
America and I'm so proud of his cap
former cabinet members and National
Republicans who are coming forward and
saying just that that this man is
uniquely unqualified for this moment in
history and he is cheapened to me the
the the greatest ideal in all of
humanity which America has stripped
Straus has striven in every generation
to make manifest in this world is that
we are a nation of love where we love
one another he is so failed to be in the
fight to make us a more loving nation or
as king would say a more beloved
community and I am I am
I have so so much hurt for what he's
done to people and I've watched it I've
watched people we call some countries
[ __ ] countries I've seen people
immigrants come to me begging me to do
something about it I've watched him
degrade you know I talked to a college
friend of mine whose kid was in the ED
lock-in at Lafayette in Lafayette Park
when he stormed in had people storm in
with with rubber bullets and tear gas
and the anguish that somebody would
think in this sacred capital where
people from the march on Washington to
second Amendment rights people have come
for generations to peacefully petition
their government and he just tramples
that for what a national security issue
because he had to urgently get someone
know but to hold up a book that he
should read that talks about humility
and the meek so I I can't give him more
of my energy I want to give it to to us
I want to give it to love I want to give
it to good people who right now don't
understand the urgency for them to act
that's where I want to give it and so I
don't want to he's not the center of my
concern and I appreciate you having a
show that that reflects that well I you
know I have not wanted to do Trump jokes
or make it all about Donald Trump
because ultimately I find him very
uninteresting and and and his action
saddened me but I I'm angry I reserved
my anger for people that enable him
that's what makes me angry and I get
very angry at people who do know better
who are in a party that maybe in the
short term benefiting from the fact that
he holds that office but in the long
term I don't know how they're going to
be able to talk to their kid to their
grandchildren and so I've been very
moved by especially the military
leadership that's come forward mattis
Kelly
most recently : Powell that is something
that the Republican Party does
show respect for is our military
leadership and when you have these
prominent members of the military
speaking out that my heart swells with
pride and I'm very happy that that that
people are coming forward I just wish
there were more I wish there were more
people who would step forward and say
you know what yes we got some good court
appointments yes we got some stuff done
because we had someone in the Oval
Office who would do our bidding but this
is too much you know I wish we'd hear
from from from more politicians like
that well we've heard the throughout
history the bystander King talked about
we have to repent in our day and age not
for the simply for the vitriolic words
and violent actions of the bad people
but the silence in action the good
people so I think I think that you're
right
and I think that this again is that
moment in American history and I and I
actually feel sorry for the Republican
Party because there's a lot of his
primary opponents in 2016 15 and 16 said
they predicted Lindsey Graham all of
them predicted he would destroy the
Republican Party and a lot of them have
gone silent now and are refusing to tell
the truth of the perversion the meanness
that he's Cavalier in the meanness that
isn't it the heart of a lot of
Republicans you name some of them like
Colin Powell and so this is ultimately a
test and a test isn't over this is a
president who could disrespect a
peaceful transition of power in 150 days
if he lose he's already trying to be
legitimize the election this is a
president is capable has shown us he's
capable of anything
and so the stress tests on this nation
over the next hundred and fifty hundred
and sixty days are gonna be great and
and this is a defining moment for all of
us and in a defining moment you're not
defined by what happens to you this
guy's capable of anything
you were always defined by how you
choose to respond and I agree with you
I'm happy for those who have decided to
respond by not silenced but by speaking
up by lifting their voices to be heard
by history I keep and you know
I hate to be I don't want to have a
false note of optimism but I've been
looking for that and I've we started out
this conversation by by talking about
Rodney King that felt like it was a
moment that then passed this feels like
it has the potential to be a moment that
lasts a moment that continues I'd like
it to be I'd like it to be a moment
where we don't say okay we made it
through that and now things have calmed
down I'd like to believe that there's
going to be lasting change and I do
think the fact that we are now it's been
over two weeks and we are still seeing
an incredible amount of unity in the
reaction to how to George Floyd's death
but also just the history of how common
this was this was not a surprise to
black people his death it was sadly it
would it it shocked many other people
but that you know sadly was not a shock
to people in the african-american
community not not at all and and I think
the African American community has had
to find a way to work through
disappointment over and over again and
betrayal over and over again and I just
think about this last week where Senator
Harris and I were on the floor to try to
meet a moment where all the house and
members of the House of Representatives
but for voted for an anti-lynching bill
that ninety nine senators understand
that this has been a bill that has been
tried over 200 times well over a century
to pass failing over and over again at
this country with the most shameful
history that we don't teach adequately
in high school or even college but the
the greatest periods of domestic
terrorism we've ever seen thousands of
African Americans being lynched not to
mention disappearing or being beaten and
we we were on the verge of passing yet
again and and we
failed because the senator objected to
it and and so I just think that that's
the moment we have to recognize civil
rights legislation failed for decades
and decades until it passed suffrage
movement failed over and over and over
again until it passed and the people
that can work through heartbreak and
recognize the heart that's not one organ
that keeps beating even though it's
broken that that's what we we need to be
sustained by so I'm a prisoner of hope
just like you but hope will get slain in
fact a message where King was killed if
you go to little rent Lorraine Motel
right now and look down and and it's
words from the Torah and from the from
the Bible or written there where King
was slain it says behold the words of
Joseph's brothers before they killed
Joseph it says behold here cometh the
dreamer let us slay him and see what
becomes of his dream and I really think
that that's the moment we're in right
now in America is what will become of
our dream heroes have been slain martyrs
have been made but it's up to us the
living to answer that question because
the dream of this country is we're still
in search of it we it still beckons to
us from beyond our grasp and I'm just
hoping that we can be the nation that
together comes comes forward and says
not on my watch will we lose this dream
in fact we will advance it for the next
generation and if we can do that and now
I will I will
this could be the greatest era often
sometimes you have to face the darkest
of times for America to lurch forward
this could actually be one of the
greatest periods right in front of us of
national advancement where we make this
a more loving nation we're not just in
words could sentimentality is easy but
we can make it in substance in our laws
and that's that's fine that's my hope
that's my dream well an absolute honor
to talk to you senator and I hear you
and I think a lot of people hear you and
I think a lot of people are committed to
making this a day-in day-out
I'm gonna call it an exercise struggle
but just through action
you know rather than sentimentality and
then hoping someone straightens this out
because y'all have to we all have to
dive in Oh your lips to God's ears thank
you no one's listening to me that guy
stopped listening to me a long time ago
I don't know God's gender but God's God
seemed too much of my foolishness over
the years but really thank you so much I
know you're very busy and I know you're
doing very important work and so bless
you for taking the time today I really
appreciate it thank you my friend thank
you so much take care I salute you I
don't even know if that's the proper
next time we talk I'll have shaved my
head all about fighting to me if that
ever happened truly you gave all caps on
that would be enough maybe we'll do that
because this thing I'm sure is going to
look hideous you know you can put off I
cannot pull it off I'd be very happy
result have a great day and thank you
very much thank you thank you Karen
thank you bye bye bye